if you have small children in your family
try this experiment you ask what
is the plural of the word dog they
will probably look at you with
wide eyes for a few seconds with
no idea what you are talking about
now this pretend i have a dog
if i get another i have  two by the
time they figure it out i bet you
anything they'll laugh and take away dogs
so what happened here technically
both questions had exactly the
same answer how can a kid
so easily produce a
plural noun when he has no idea  what the
hell is a plural of hello my name is
luca from luca lampariello dotcom and
you may be surprised but the
answer holds the key
to learning
the grammar of a foreign language for you or anyone else
a child's inability to use
plurals  grammatical problems without even knowing
what plural means is not an anomaly
ask the child literally to conjugate
a verb or to identify  than the
direct object of a sentence and you will feel
equally lost even though you do
both hundreds of times a day
again we are forced to
ask how a child can now
fluent English Italian Polish or any
language without any
knowledge of grammatical terms
and what  which is even more annoying
if a child can speak a native language
without all this complicated
grammar study because i a
functioning adult struggle with a language after
spending countless hours with my head in
grammar books the answers to
these questions reveal the existence  of
two completely different ways of learning grammar
one very effective
and one very ineffective in most
cases the first way
children use is called implicit learning the
second way adults use and
often suffer is called
explicit learning learning implicitly
means  learn through
exposure and interaction by participating
in a  a meaningful communication in a
positive emotional environment this is
what children do and what they do
consistently for years learning
explicitly means learning
through lots of direct instruction
lectures textbook readings
and complicated written explanations
this is what young adults do
and adults in high
school college and beyond explicit learning
is pretty much the opposite of
implicit learning and the
results show that especially when
learning skills like languages
now you may not be convinced
implicit learning and
explicit learning may seem like terms
sophisticated techniques used to
describe what is essentially the
same learning but don't believe me the
difference between implicit learning and
explicit learning is huge and is
something that scientists have
directly observed for themselves in action in
1953 a well known man  by science
as stem not to be confused with
clothing giant and senen had
part of his brain removed due to
health issues in particular he lost his
amygdala hippocampus along with some
other key brain components
as a result made in had no memory
episodic could eat breakfast and then
forget what happened 5
later could have a whole conversation
with someone and then
soon forget they ever existed
despite this he could remember some things
not facts not events but
skills could be taught to navigate a
maze a  tracing a pattern on a
page while looking in a mirror today
would make it better and faster she wouldn't
remember learning that maze
to trace this pattern but something in her
brain retained the practice she
could still develop skills just
like brainy people  normal
although you would not be able to
consciously recognize that you have done them
before to say so  succinctly
could be learned implicitly but not
explicitly he didn't care about
facts or events but ask him to
practice a task over and over again and he
might get better at it just like you and I
would the story of elche helped
me scientists learn that
implicit and explicit learning are
completely different processes that
occur in separate parts of
the brain as human beings we
lean on both at different points
and sometimes together but still remain
separate from each
other ok back to the present i have
shared with you the story of made
in  so you can start thinking about
your brain in terms of
implicit and explicit learning the way you
use each defines
your language learning outcomes so
what does this mean for you and the way
you learn grammar
let's first briefly discuss the ways
in  that you can use
implicit learning to more
effectively learn the  grammar of your target language
mass exposure you need to expose yourself to
your target language as much as you can the
more exposure to audio texts
and videos the better read and listen to as
much authentic language as you can
find comprehensible input when
choosing material for your
mass exposure start with things  that you can
understand for the most part this seems
obvious but it is not if you participate in
content that you understand little and that
you have other means of support like a
vocabulary list at the end translation
or some grammar notes loose
meaningful interaction with human beings
as well as the
Children's early experiences are filled with
countless interactions with parents and
loved ones. You should try to fill your
language learning with significant time
spent with
tutor friends and language partners.
Nowadays it's not too difficult to make
new connections online so
even if  you can't hang out in
pe  You have the option to connect
by skype or zoom live as many
experiences as
if you want to learn a language
naturally you need to live the language
that means after you have
spent time reading books you should
go out and try to use and experience the
language in a world  real travel attend
meetings hike go to the movies
try to experience life as much as
you can but through your target language
use emotions emotions play
a key role in the way we
remember things even grammatical rules
make sure most
part of what you do in your target language
consists of things that you find
fun interesting and emotionally
impactful
now let's take a look at what you can
do when it comes to
explicit learning use grammar books
but for reference only
grammar books should not be read  from cover to cover you will
consult rarely and only for a
very quick clarification do not let yourself be
im  plant for the technical details and if
you can take notes in your own
words for further memorization of
the finer details practice
language awareness
most people are unaware of how they
speak the words they choose the
mistakes they make and even their
facial features or body language when speaking
developing awareness of
grammatical errors they make
while producing that language is key
if you want to improve get
feedback although you can
discover a lot for yourself
through practice and
occasional glances at our grammar book
ability to write things down
has its limits it
is essential to consult
native speakers to get feedback on
your mistakes because even there are mistakes
you don't know you are making
implement feedback receiving
feedback
is not enough you need to implement it
to improve how many times it has received
a correction  and then
the same mistake is being made
over and over again that's because your will
to perfect your grammar was
not strong enough you must
constantly strive to avoid repeating the
same mistakes failing to make this
often clear but the more practical
the implementation of  comments you better
talk one final important note
some people think you don't
need to learn grammar at all they
have the books stay away from
any grammar explanation just
trust understandable input or
understandable input i don't think this is
the best way to do things i
think  as an adult you need a certain
amount of explicit grammatical explanations
an amount that depends
mainly on the
linguistic distance between your native language and your
target language the closer
the languages ​​are the more characteristics they have
in common an Italian learning Spanish
can learn the language without the need
for  opened  r a grammar book
simply because Spanish Italian
are very similar an Italian
learning Japanese on the other hand might
need to spend much more time
implicitly and explicitly learning
how Japanese grammar works
considering that the languages ​​differ so
much in terms of syntax,
vocabulary and morphology  and one
more observation the greater the
distance between your mother tongue and
the target or target language the
longer it will take you to assimilate those
grammatical patterns safely
no matter how smart and
diligent you are there will be many times when
you will forget a  grammatical pattern this
is unavoidable even if you read and reread
your notes a dozen times as
a language student it is extremely
important to understand that this is the
time of the marathon where you need to
show great stamina to
succeed otherwise you can
easily lose motivation  as a
general rule try to divide  your
implicit and explicit learning time
according to the pareto principle
80% of the time should be spent
learning implicitly while the
other 20% should be
learning explicitly so in
closing it is important to emphasize that
human beings absorb
language more effectively  through a
process called implicit learning the
opposite process called
explicit learning is effective for memorizing
facts and events but less for
developing skills such as language
as adults we must strive to
learn grammar
mainly implicitly but we must also
use its explicit learning tools
to help us bridge the
gap when you need to focus
on learning raw,
authentic language for most of your
learning but then open up a
grammar book for those rare moments when
you need a little push to
help you grasp a concept if
want to learn more about
implicit and explicit learning be
sure to watch and in the description
of this video where you will see a link to my
blog where I have shared a great
article on the subject as always
thanks for watching and see you
in the next video
[Music  ]